hey folks
um hopefully
you are here to hear me talk about um
managing asynchronous apis and by what i
mean by that
well i mean that we
need to talk a little bit about the idea
of
if we have asynchronous apis and explain
what i mean by that in a minute how do
we manage them i talk a lot at various
conferences about building them once
you've got one how are you going to own
it
okay who am i so my name is ian cooper
some of you may know me from talks about
test driven development or event driven
architecture
i've been doing this a while i used to
have hair on my head
and i used to have a beard that had some
dark color in it
but the point i really try and draw out
is i'm just like you i'm just another
developer i'm not particularly smarter
because i happen to be on this stage i'm
just sharing experience
um you know
we are
all of us capable of doing all of the
stuff that i'm talking about today so
please don't feel it's kind of expert to
learner here
i work on an open source project if you
are a net developer particularly we
provide a messaging framework
um we cover the functionality of
something like mediator but we then also
let you work out of process
uh and using messaging transport
uh we've got a v9 release coming out a
couple of weeks with better support for
outboxes and things like entity
framework call if you're a python
developer we have a python version but
it's languishing a bit and needs some
love
his agenda that's probably a bit wrong
uh i'm knocking off a deck over there
because i've got some av issues
um
but we'll talk about endpoints what are
they and what i mean by endpoints we'll
talk about how we discover endpoints
and then we'll talk about there's more
than just facing kpi some
things that help us with the process of
endpoint discovery
all right
so first of all i think i should
probably define what i mean by an
asynchronous api or
uh
what are we talking about so a
synchronous conversation
is one where both parties are present
and it fails
if that's not true if you can't pick up
the second you know the phone call and
answer that synchronous conversation
will fail it requires both parties to be
present when it happens
typical example a phone call
right i pick up the phone and i phone
you that conversation is synchronous
grpc http those kind of protocols i tend
to be synchronous right i call you the
server needs to be online and present
an asynchronous conversation is one
where both parties don't need to be
present
what happens is you deliver to some kind
of mailbox
a message queue is really just a mailbox
and the work sits there
until the person effectively who is the
receiver decides they want to pick it up
and process it
and that obviously has lots of useful
properties
the receiver doesn't have to actually be
up when you send the message
and the receiver can throttle they can
decide
when and at what rate they want to
consume messages
snail mail is the classic example but we
all use messaging apps today like you
know whatsapp signal whatever your
preference is
the only person that phones me
is my
mum everybody else just sends me a
whatsapp message or a signal message or
a text
and they do that
because it's really inconvenient to call
me and i'm not there that you can't get
anything done right you send me a
message i can just pick it up and deal
with it when i'm ready
um
and my mom likes to hear my voice right
but everybody else just sends me a
message
and the same is really true of our
software today
it is a lot more robust
to send somebody a message and let them
put it in an outbox let them get to it
when they can let them process it when
they have availability to do so
then it is to demand that the other
party is up and running when you send
them a message
and that's why
we try and push particularly in
microservices world i shift to
asynchronous apis a lot
this talk is not about why you should
use asynchronous apis however with a lot
of other talks i give others to give
about that but it's more about once you
have them how do you how do you look
after them
how do you own them
all right one of the words i'm going to
use here is end point what do i mean by
an endpoint i'm actually going to use a
definition that comes from microsoft and
from the days of windows communication
foundation i think it's a pretty good
definition
it's places where messages are sent or
received that's what we mean by the end
point your application has an end point
you may be using it to send messages you
may be using it to receive messages you
may be using it to do both in an app
quite often our app sends and receive
messages
right
and by that really as an end point we
don't necessarily have to mean an
asynchronous protocol it could well be a
synchronous protocol
and generally when we think about an
endpoint we want to know a number of
things
we want to know
what's the message that i'm going to
send or receive on this end point
if i am
the receiver
i might want to know where it's coming
from if i'm the sender i might want to
know where it's going to
and i'm likely want to know how i send
it and by how we mean things like
am i sending this over http am i sending
this basically via kafka am i sending
this
via
amqp
if i have those pieces of information
i know enough to communicate
let's take a little detour for a moment
into the main drum design as an idea
so in the main drum design we have
basically a domain right currently i
work for adjusted takeaway so i work in
the domain of delivering takeaway food
to your doorstep
and within that domain
we may identify what we call subdomains
little bits of that puzzle right
so i tend to focus sub domains on
business processes so it might be
checkout order
fulfill order place order
um
provide menu right
those kind of business processes
and their sub domains it's easier for us
to reason about and think about those
right
and what we tend to do
as software engineers
or architects
is we model that sub domain we say let's
model this particular sub domain and
let's write some code to implement the
sub-domain let's create some schemers to
implement that sub-domain and let's have
a language we use within that sub-domain
and the product team to talk about the
concepts let's create a shared
understanding of that subdomain
now sometimes
we don't get the world right and our
bounded contexts don't align very well
with our sub domains that's generally a
historical situation where the sub
domains change our view the subdomains
change we've got legacy bounded context
and mapping gets more complicated but
let's assume we have a better world
where our sub domains and our bounded
contexts align quite well for the moment
and typically
our microservices represent
the sub domains on microservices and
therefore bounded context don't get that
wrong by the way it's not really about
microservices being bounded contexts
when we talk about what microservices
target it's really about microservices
targeting sub-domains and thereby being
a bounded context
all right
we name about the context right so i've
got two here restaurant management in
other words that talks about getting
restaurants onto our platform restaurant
availability is the restaurant open is
the restaurant serving food how long
will it take the restaurant to serve
food all right
um has the restaurant had some terrible
kitchen disaster and needs to close for
half an hour
okay
and you'll notice
we may have shared concepts
restaurant management is going to tell
restaurant availability about
restaurants in their opening hours etc
and the question really is how these two
begin to communicate
how are we going to communicate between
restaurant management restaurant
availability about life and things right
and particularly how we're going to
communicate about shared concepts like
restaurant
because we have different models
i'm moderating restaurant availability
i'm modeling restaurant management
they're two different teams two
different sets of code two different
schemas probably two different product
owners and we think about things
differently in restaurant availability i
really care a lot about hours i care
about the hard problems about scheduling
during time zone changes and
restaurant management i care about
getting people on board signing a
contract who's the contact detail where
they're located right
so we have to kind of come up with some
agreement about information that we'll
share
and we tend to think about the idea of
there being an upstream and a downstream
team
and what do we mean by that well
generally in a relationship somebody is
producing information and somebody's
consuming it and the producer is kind of
upstreaming the consumers downstream and
the reason we talk about those that
particular metaphor is if you are
upstream of somebody like you're a city
and you pollute the water
the poor old people downstream have to
deal
with your behavior
so the problem is
there's no real constraint on the
upstream team on what they do
but the downstream team continuously
suffer as a result
so we try and do is say well we should
have a customer supplier relationship
people upstream should be suppliers
people downstream should be their
customers
and the suppliers should try to look
after and take care of their customers
they shouldn't abuse their privilege of
being upstream
they should say hey
how would you what quality would you
like for your water
should we color it today i don't know
whatever
all right
so the bad world
is called conformance
and that says the upstream team just
says you know what
i've got a data structure around
restaurants
i'm just going to publish that
from our point of view talking about a
tinklist conversations
they're publishing an event
but it could be this is generally
applicable to all
kind of interactions between two
services
if i just publish it i publish my
internal structure
downstream teams start consuming it they
conform
to the structure basically the upstream
team uses
one day the upstream team says oh you
know
i think we should change the way that id
works
um
we switched from using sql server to
dynamo and it turns out you know that
old incrementing identity value we use
is not going to work for us let's have a
good somebody goes yeah let's make that
change a few days later upstream team
changes their event model yeah hey
downstream teams start saying
everything's broken we don't understand
why what happened
right
a downstream team is dependent on the
schema that the upstream team uses
internally they'll just break
so the problem with this conformance
model is it's really antithetical to one
of the key properties of microservices
which is independent deployability
the restaurant management team ought to
be able to change their internal code
base they ought to be able to change
uh their
that the schema in the data store it's
not good to change their data store
and it shouldn't have an effect on
restaurant availability
they should be able to just keep working
along just as they did yesterday getting
useful restaurant information
so the first rule really is we don't
want to publish
our internal representations
straight onto the wire
because the problem is
we will break our consumers
now what the downstream coup team could
do is introduce an anti-corruption layer
they say all right we'll write something
defensive it'll listen to whatever we
get from upstream
and it will convert it into the
representation that we want to
see and we want to depend upon
so we'll take whatever version and
restaurant they're giving us and we'll
convert it into something looks like the
restaurant we expect oh they've changed
the id value
fine we'll we'll cope on our side we'll
do something in our anti-corruption
layer to
put in an id number that basically is we
can understand
and that works
but it's not very effective right
because every downstream team that
listens to restaurant management is now
writing an anti-corruption lad to
protect themselves against the bad
behavior of the folks upstream so it's a
great defensive measure if we don't
control restaurant management if they're
outside of our purview they're a third
party that we don't trust very much
but if they're part of our organization
they can behave better
so what we do is we say
they're a supplier
we should have a contract with them
and the contract agrees what they will
supply to us
and they will agree
what the model of a restaurant is
that they will give us
and they will agree that that model
won't just change every five minutes
but they'll try and produce changes that
are backwards compatible
we will agree probably what we call a
tolerant reader
that means if somebody adds a field we
don't depend on that's okay we can
ignore that
maybe we'll agree with the upstream team
that there are certain defaults we can
use sensibly and in the event that the
information is not there we'll just swap
in one of our defaults
and that allows the upstream team to
make some changes they can add new
fields for new customers right
we'll just ignore those
but otherwise we try and remain
consistent
and if someone's going to create a
breaking chains like changing identifier
from an integer to a string
we'll have a discussion about how best
to manage that we'll have to version the
contract
we'll have to come up with some approach
like providing both identifiers for a
period of time until we can all move
over
but it's a contract and it's a process
of negotiation and agreement between two
parties
and the thing is it frees the upstream
team restaurant management can now
change their internals as much as they
like
without fear
that they're going to break everyone
downstream because they're continuing to
honor the contract
and we talk about this as necessary
coupling
we all
as software engineers and architects i'm
sure
um
recognize that what we want is high
cohesion and low coupling right
particularly if we have kind of micro
services we recognize the goal is low
coupling i want to release my micro
service without talking to you about
that release
so we recognize you know we don't want
too much coupling but some coupling
isn't is necessary right
if i don't couple at all
well no one's using my service it's not
doing anything
right no one can talk to me
and i'm in perfect isolation i'm
probably not offering a lot of value
so folks want to talk to me so there's a
certain amount of necessary coupling
you have to talk to me to get my job
done we're going to have to agree to
couple
so we want to manage that coupling
and we manage that kelvin by thinking
about it as a contract
we've taken this risk the decision to
couple to you hey we'll do that by
contract so it won't change that stuff
because we know that people could couple
to it
and therefore we want to manage their
ability to change so we won't keep
forcing
changes on them
so we can talk about basically creating
some kind of habitable relationship with
both the supplier and the consumer we
have a contract
and that contract allows us both to
survive the fact that we've coupled
together
anyone familiar with promise theory can
understand that essentially what's
happening is that we can think of the
micro service as kind of a super agent
it's able to make promises about its own
behavior and it can say i can make
promises to you
contracts
about what i will expose in the future
and an end point is really just this
contract
that i am making
to other services
about what i'm going to provide
and really it consists of a contract a
binding
and an address sometimes in wcf where we
used to call it the abc's of a contract
remember we said basically uh where
messages should be sent how they should
be sent and what they look like what
they look like is the contract
where they should be sent is the address
and the binding is how they should be
sent
okay i thought another little
slide there
okay
i i i will move on a little bit i may
have a
need to
just change an av issue in a second with
the
glass in the second hour if i get to it
i will
uh you may have the current version so
all right
one of the questions then i might want
to ask is
how do i discover these endpoints
someone documents my their contract
and there's a
service say i need to know about
restaurants
where am i going to find that
information
now lots of orgs typical problem spaces
i go on slack
and i ask everybody i said anyone know
who creates restaurants
because i can't find where it is and i
need a restaurant for my service
or the other thing typically that
happens in august is someone goes okay
i'll just search our enterprise github
and see if i can find messages entitled
restaurants
that'll be what i need to do to solve
this problem
and as you can imagine that's not really
a perfect world right
if i am the provider of a message
i'm going to have a similar problem
my problem is going to be i don't know
who consumes my messages
i know that i produce this message which
tells me that the restaurant hours have
changed
but who consumes it it might be nice to
know that sometimes now i don't want to
couple to them
that's certainly a bad thing right
but what i do want to do
is sometimes say well
hey
have i got some consumers of this
message
that's a little bit of a problem right
because
where am i going to find it
again the problem seems to come down to
this usually most organizations
what i'm going to do is go on to slack
and ask a question and say hey
everybody
can you tell me
who consumes my message
if you use it
and that's not really that useful right
so if the only way we are documenting
our messages
is to document them by essentially
putting the information on our github
repo in a markdown file where we kind of
say oh here's our message structure or
oh here basically is the code that
represents the endpoint
it's very difficult for us to
communicate with other people
germany people need to know a number of
things they want to know what is the
content type of our message and probably
what they also want to know what the
encoding is as well
okay
they may want to know
what's the schema of the message
what does it look like what's the shape
of it what are its fields
we probably also want to know what
metadata has been supplied what matters
we mean the headers
so we may have header information which
helps us process the message
we haven't defined that
it's going to be really hard for us to
basically work with those messages
we may want to know what protocol we
need
to use to talk about it
do you talk kafka do you talk sns
do you talk amqp
how can i talk to you
all these pieces of information are some
something we're going to have to
discover in order to use your service
so we can think about our endpoint which
we defined as basically these abcs right
i need to know the contract i need to
know the binding i need to know the
address
and we can say basically we're going to
need to document our message the thing
that we send or receive
we're going to need to document probably
both the headers and the payload of that
message what headers do you have
what what do they contain
do you have tracing information
look at what is the content type
um what is the content encoding
do you have a message id do you have
some kind of correlation id do you tell
us where you replied to on reply
messages
we're going to understand the channel
where does this message travel channels
in messaging uh quite often
sort of a pipe between the producer and
consumer over which stuff flows in a
single direction and they're quite often
given a logical address and in most
messaging platforms we think about a
topic or a routine key so a mqp091
rabbit is a routine key in kafka or sns
it's a topic right where am i sending
this
where can you subscribe to it how could
you possibly listen to the message
and what's the binding
right if i'm going to listen to this
message on this channel and pull it off
what do i need to do you i need to use
kafka do i use google pub sub
right you need to document all those
things
all right
you just give me a second i'm going to
get
uh just upload a different
a later version of this presentation
because he's
so the av is not working within a laptop
so he's got my deck over there
and i just need
to get him to start downloading a new
version if you give me a second
i apologize for interruption
oh okay
all right see me two seconds while i get
him to do the
update and then
i will have
i'm just missing a couple of slides that
i want you to see
it will take me two seconds to get this
guy to do it
sorry i think i've got a slightly older
version can you just get to
that github and keep her if you just do
search for github in cooper
just touch it just search githubby and
keeper i can find
yeah
and i should have a newer version i just
uploaded it
the time
it's just the managing async for you
guys and
for managing yep
she just committed it one minute ago
yeah that's one minute ago
just download it click the down button
to the the download because it's a
binary uh cert then you just play that
one
and that'll be the correct version
thank you
all right
it's amazing isn't it quite how
we've reached 2021 but we still don't
really have
uh
but av can still be a trial for us all
all right
hopefully you get a nice um recap as it
speeds through
so you can all go wow fantastic ian
remember to put a recap into his talk
so that when i was confused
i could see all the slides was passed
um
you regret animation when you have to
whiz through everything at high speed
don't you
you didn't see that slide but don't
worry it's just basically saying that we
need to document async
asynchronous apis as well as synchronous
apis and that's why i knew i had a
slightly older version of the deck
all right
there you go
so one of the major games in town is 18
kpi 18 kpi represents basically uh an
emerging standard for documenting your
endpoints it's recently become part of
the linux foundation so and it has a
very open governance model there are
some key kind of project owners but then
effectively it has very open
contribution model has a community on
slack you can all go and get involved
and help define it
and they're a lovely lovely bunch and
they have kind of regular zoom meetings
you can kind of join in and they're all
over the world so lovely bunch and what
they give you is a specification for
defining an api
um uh and then they give you tools which
we'll look at a little bit uh during the
session
which say well given you've defined this
api json yaml i can parse that
and i can run a tool chain for you
and there are emerging community-based
tools around it as well
so the way async kpi works it says well
there's a producer and a consumer
and there are roles my app could take
because on my app i might send some
messages and i might listen to some
messages so i can be in both a producer
and a consumer role
and i send a message over a channel to
what we hope before right so a channel
has this logical construction given a
name where i'm going to send a message
has to be addressable
because essentially i must be able to
send to an address is really a name
and channels are usually hosted on a
server
now in async api 2
generally the server abstraction if
we're using messaging via broker is a
little bit redundant we'll talk about in
a second
if you've seen something like web
sockets the server is a role
one of you will be playing like the
producer if you're producing messages
you'll effectively be the server
we'll come back to the server a little
bit later
okay
we send a message and it has a payload
and a header
and as a protocol
or called a binding
which tells us
how are we going to use a specific
protocol like kafka or an sns to send
this how are we going to configure that
to work
so an async kpi specification has a top
level object called an 18kpi object some
of you who've done open api may find
this model
familiar and that's because open api was
an inspiration to the async api team
when they began working they looked at
the way open api i was able to document
http endpoints and said wouldn't it be
great if we had something similar for
doing messaging particularly in their
case i think web sockets
info object is a top level object which
says
what is this specification about
right it's metadata about the
specification who should i talk to which
team in the organization owns this
endpoint
the service object says
okay
what hosts effectively this
endpoint
and the channels object says
what are the channels what are the
things over which messages are flowing
and within the channels object because
you may have more than one channel
because you both send and receive you
have operations
saying i'm going to send something or
i'm going to receive something
and they have under the operation a
message saying what i send or receive
there's a component section and what
that lets us do is
take common repeated bits of definition
like message schemas put them in a
central place
and tags so i can effectively tag my
spec for purposes of searching etc
okay
so the top level object really has just
one property an id which is identifier
of the app the specification is for you
right specification for a given app so
you would write one for a micro service
the info object has some useful
information
i've just documented
for
fun and giggles um
one of our sample applications in the
budget project
and it has stuff like saying well where
do you go to find help about this where
would you go for support don't email
that email it doesn't exist
and a license information which is a bit
strange
if it's internal you just put something
like local
it's a required field which is a bit
weird
a description effectively of what the
specification represents right so
someone reading this can go oh okay this
is the tech for that app
um a version number in other words
essentially which version the
specification is this so i can
effectively version and iterate my
specifications if i have to move forward
it's a contract it should have a version
and tags
the service object you can have multiple
servers so you can do production staging
qri i'm just defining a local one here
and the protocol how do i talk to the
server that effectively is working here
and then perhaps most importantly the
channel
so the channel is what i'm communicating
over so i'm defining a channel called
greeting in say kafka this would be a
topic
right
i describe an operation on it subscribe
i'll come back to subscribe in just a
second
the operation id is really used for code
gen saying what would i call this
particular operation if i co-gen
something around it and then i say
what's the summary of what i'm doing and
what's the description of what i'm doing
right and then what's the message that
goes over the channel with this
operation
notice that although all the description
says i am sending something the
operation is subscribe why is that
well
because of the
history of async api what it's defining
is
what operations do i expose
to you
and if i am a publisher
i expose the subscribe operation you can
subscribe to my messages
if i am a consumer i expose the publish
operation you can publish to me
that makes sense in the kind of
websockets world it came from it doesn't
make so much sense in a pub sub world
and we'll come back to that again at the
end as i say
a ref
is a way of saying inspect you saw one
on the on the previous page
see a ref for the message
right a ref says
hey
i'm not going to define that here it's
somewhere else in the spec because it's
shared
typically a message might be used in
multiple places and so here i'm doing a
ref where it just says actually you can
find it in the same document in the
component section
and here i'm saying actually it's in
this other file in the component section
the other file one's quite useful
because as you can imagine i've got two
apps one is sending message the other is
receiving a message i can have a shared
definition file with a message in it and
share it between the two apps
that's what a component section looks
like
you can see that effectively i have a
schema for a message
and it has internally refs to describe
the payload the traits are aware of
providing common header reuse
and a schema for the message
uh out of the box
async api supports json schema to
describe its messages but it is open to
any format and we'll describe some other
formats in a second you could use
right
so it doesn't it isn't constrained to
saying you must describe your messages
in json schema easy to tell it you just
need to document what you're describing
your message format in
so the structure
how well does that map
to the requirement we gave earlier
around basically an endpoint consisting
of a message with a payload and a header
a channel what do we send it over and a
binding
well
we've got some information about the
endpoint right
and really though a bit strangely when
we talk about basically channels and
operations the things that the endpoint
makes available they're actually a bit
closer to kind of our general endpoint
description
we certainly in the operation have a
message which describes the message with
a payload and a header
we have also this weird servers object
for hosting a channel
and the binding information which
describes how a given protocol
supports stuff so what happens is you
add binding information say to operation
etcetera to describe how your protocol
supports that
um
is spread throughout
so there's currently discussion in the
asia cafe community about a v3
and v3 the intent is ready to support
pub sub a bit better make it a bit more
intuitive
so what you can see is the operations
have been taken out from under channels
i made a top level item
so you're saying my app sends some stuff
and my app receives some stuff that's
the action you can see there
and it does that over a channel which
i've defined elsewhere
and you can say in its bindings
hey
am i actually a server or do i just use
a piece of middleware to do that
so there'd be a better support for pub
sub and v3 yet some of the details there
are still under kind of development
um and it's time to infl it's good time
to go try and influence that spec if
you're interested in that kind of thing
um but better support for pub sub is
coming it's very usable today um we we
use it to define
uh producers and consumers
it's just a little bit you have to
explain counterintuitive stuff like why
is it published versus subscribe at this
point right
i've taken that feedback and it's the
next iteration i think should be very
exciting two is definitely kind of early
adopters people giving feedback
three i think is probably where early
majority will come in
okay
um there is tooling they provide
basically your studio you can write the
yaml or your json or display something
looks like html we'll come back to that
what documentation
you can put it in visual studio code if
you like and it will basically do the
same thing for you
backstage and other
similar libs are starting to support
async api
what's backstage is for backstage if you
don't know it comes out of spotify and
it's really a
portal for us to put developer
documentation
so if i want to discover
what
services do we have and what events do
they expose i can use something like
backstage to hold my 18kpi documentation
so developers can discover
what endpoints look like
there's also tooling emerging from the
community this one i don't think is
perfect what it does but you can see
that it's possible once you have
definitions for your endpoints to begin
to graphing out the flow
and
visibility
of event based of asynchronous apis is a
real problem right how do i know what's
actually going on under the hood
this gives you a kind of static
viewpoint it lets you say
at a design level
what would the flight messages in my
system look like
we'll talk about operational
understanding of that in a bit
okay so we said it supports json schema
it also supports other formats what are
the ways of describing our actual
message
one of the big emerging standards in a
minute is cloud events
so cloud events is across a number of
vendors
really across the people that compete
with aws because aws are not part of the
cloud event standard but it's an
interesting and quite useful uh tool to
use
card events is focused on events let's
just define commands and events for a
second right
a command is an instruction my example
is usually make me a cup of tea
an event is basically a fact i am
thirsty
event sent me one way i broadcast it i
don't know if anyone's ever going to
respond to it i just broadcast that fact
commands often imply a reply please make
me a cup of tea i'm expecting to get a
cup of tea
commands typically i know the recipient
i'm addressing somebody and giving them
an instruction
events don't have any knowledge
basically of who actually subscribes it
maybe nobody listening for all you care
one recipient or zero to many
subscribers
cloud events has focused itself on
events
hence the name
so they've deliberately restricted the
scope of their work
and as such
the specification has nothing really
about routing
right it has does it it considers that
protocol specific concern and it also
considers that events may flow and may
change who they're between at any one
time so things like reply to
or to
these are not things that you will find
the topic you won't find those in cloud
events doesn't mean you can't use them
but it means it's not covered by the
standard
okay
generally cloud events is basically
concerned with the metadata more than
anything else
all right
so it says my event consists of metadata
and a payload
and my metadata consists of required and
optional attributes
i have an identifier for basically my
message
and a source message
right
so
this application sent it and it had this
id between the two of those it's unique
ids could repeat
between
uh
people sending a message but for any
given producer the id should be unique
spec version so which version of cloud
events are you basically defining it
with
and a type
so basically it's the kind of name in
the message like my greetings message
and generally the version information
goes here like grouping v1 greeting v2
if you have written information
optional attributes you don't require
them
it makes assumptions otherwise
what is the content type what is the
mime type basically of this
message application json application
avro right
what is the data schema what does the
payload look like
notice
that cloud events is not defining
payloads
so cloud events is perfectly usable
with async api
async api can how you can have a json
description of the schema of your
message and you can treat cloud events
instead of traits that define
the headers that your message is going
to use
subject qualifies the id and source
information with more detail if
necessary
and a time stamp when the message gets
sent
all right
there are two types of binding to
specific protocols like kafka sns http
etc
right
binary and structured
binary says
the protocol has probably got some
mechanism for handling metadata
use that mechanism
structured says just shove it all in the
payload we'll show it example in a
second
and we support a range of bindings okay
uh if your binding's not there
they are pretty good at taking
uh contributions from the community and
some bindings have been defined kind of
outside the community
so a binary one for kafka for example
would look like this kafka and
i can't which version it came in but
kafka now supports basically headers and
messages
so those things the ce underscore are
cloud events
attributes
and that protocol has been defined so
effectively if you use cloud events with
kafka
then you can read the cloud events
attributes out basically of kafka
structured and all protocols have to
support both says
just whack it in the body of the message
in a kind of envelope fashion
makes sense
so you can see the difference one goes
in the actual headers that the protocol
supports the other just says dump it all
in the payload use a kind of envelope
model
wrap my actual payload with this
information
okay you need to be aware of what you're
reading obviously because that's how you
interpret it okay
uh you probably then once you've created
all these event schemas your payload
you need to do something with them
you could leave them in async api but
one of the things that you want to think
about is
forwards and backwards compatibility of
your schemas
so a number of tools exist out there
this is a slide from confluence schema
registry
i think there's uh one from ap curio and
i think there are a few others
and the cloud events team are working on
a
specification that let you register the
schema of the message that you produce
and consumers can register their
interest in it
such that you can determine whether or
not
your message is forwards or backwards
compatible
changes to messages are the one of the
big problems we get out there in terms
of braking systems
as we said if you're a tolerant reader
you can effectively cope with certain
changes so you can be forwards and
backwards compatible
so you'll probably want to dig out a
registry of some sort as your estate
grows bigger and register your messages
and check compatibility i would check
out confluence scheme registry you might
also want to go and look at something
like happy curio
telemetry so we mentioned that with
something like async api
what i can do
is i can essentially say here is a
static view of how messages are going to
flow through my system i can look at
those all those producer and consumer
endpoints i've defined i can graph them
and i can kind of see what the flow is
open telemetry would let you investigate
that at runtime as well
so where open telemetry works is this
idea of a a spa a trace that has spans
and a span really says hey i'm starting
some
lifetime of communication
and it can have sub spans which
represent hey i'm a worker thing that
lives inside that span so here for
example if i was going to send a message
between restaurant management restaurant
availability
i might have an overall span that begins
when i send the message
from restaurant management
and i serialize the span context into
the headers of my message
cloud events doesn't define whether
you're using open telemetry etc but it
has optional attributes it allows them
so you can define that and you yourself
and i create another span in the child
which says i'm now effectively in the
child and i'm doing work here
spans consider an operation name start
and finish time stamps the context the
span id and the trace id
and the attributes that basically are
defined
by standard and the ones you define
yourself so that you can particularly
determine what the flow is you can see
yourself flowing through these spans
open telemetry has a collector and the
collector effectively you send messages
to you from your application or you rely
on the framework or a library you're
using being built around open telemetry
and doing it for you and then you can
effectively go from that collector to
standard tracing tools
i'm not going to go into a huge detail
just because of time alex i noticed is
running a session on open telemetry
later on today in room three so if
you're interested in open telemetry and
want to know more about that i would go
and see alex's session
all right so i've built my endpoints
i've recognized their contracts i've
documented the endpoint with async api
i have used cloud events to make sure
that my metadata is consistent
uh and i can uh
i can basically then have a binding
between that and various protocols
between 18 kpi
and cloud events and my messages
um and i've registered all my events in
a schema registry okay great what other
things might help me from that toolkit
that i've got
18 kpis pretty interesting
and it's real sweet spot for me is its
parser and generator model
so what happens is i've got my
specification
and there's a parser written in
javascript
that will essentially pause that yaml
adjacent and turn it into a model
and then what i can do with what's
called the generator is i can
essentially
pass that model to a template
they support both react or
nunjucks
and i can use that template
to generate new artifacts
i'll i'll
do that okay
so this is basically a react template
and here you can see the idea that what
we're saying is okay well
why don't you have a look and see
whether or not
i'm publishing something in other words
i'm
actually means i'm subscribing and i've
got a binding of kafka
so in other words i've probably got a
protocol binding of kaska
effectively on my channel
if i have
generate a new file
with the relevant kafka information
what could i do with that
well
one of the things we've begun to do with
it is say i'll take the 18 kpi
definition
i'll use the binding information we use
sns and kafka
i've take that binding information out
put it in a json file
and i'll use polumi to generate that
infrastructure that's required for that
process
i will declare my cues i'll declare my
topics i will subscribe my cues to my
topics for sms right
so my team just declaratively says what
infrastructure do i want
drop that in there repo rate repo we
pick it up
when we build the infrastructure for
them
such that we know that infrastructure is
going to be available when they run
their app
you can do documentation the same way
yeah an infrastructure is code
the other thing you can do
is scaffolding
someone writes basically a definition
where they say i'm going to consume
these messages
if you're if you use a standard
framework internally for consuming those
messages
you can probably boil a plate a lot of
an application
that would need to be able to read
messages from that stream so we're
certainly looking at doing
boilerplate.net solutions that
effectively just say you know write your
handler code here
we'll do all the hard work of creating
the boilerplate that connects up to that
given
channel
pulls messages off it and dumps it to a
handler we're using using frameworks all
you really want to write is your domain
logic
makes it very easy
all right
and i i finished the finished at that
point
we have five minutes
so we we're live we can do questions wow
does anybody have any questions
i realize you're all norwegians and you
don't actually ask questions i've got a
question at the front
um
for like authentication requirements
okay that's a good question so the
question was does async api have
specification for authorization or other
authorization requirements yep there's a
security section on async api which lets
you say
how are we going to authorize this one
and then there's basically
protocol specific uh information quite
often on the binding which says okay
what's going on here
other questions
i can see people which is quite a
revolution
no no one's gonna think all right so uh
my i'm i cooper on twitter my dms are
always open i'm happy to talk about this
stuff and what we're doing with it um
uh for us it's definitely uh
i mean we have 2000 developers and
hundreds of services become critical to
us that we take control of that event
infrastructure because it's become
too difficult for people to discover
events and too difficult for us to
manage that event estate to manage the
infrastructure we had services declaring
their own infrastructure things when
things died who knew how you recovered
it right as a production incident
somebody accidentally deletes a queue
uh a topic in sns
right and the queues will then die
how do you know
how to effectively recreate that topic
and who subscribes to it richard all the
subscriptions right that was a real
problem for us so this is a solution to
those problems
so at sufficient scale this all becomes
really difficult
so it's kind of this uh and it's an
emerging area there's lots of emerging
standards people are working on to try
and make this better make life better as
people move towards events again
feel free to ping me about this
okay
but otherwise if you've got no more
questions i can see oh there's a
question in front
so for racing kpi the tooling is kind of
irrespective of language but you
effectively have to use javascript to
basically work with the generator pretty
much
i i there was some people writing
tooling in things like go and net to try
and do the same thing but most of those
efforts have not had a lot of traction
and the core team works on javascript
i'm not a great i'm a back end person
i'm not a great javascript developer but
even i can make the react template stuff
work it's not like it's really there's a
whole template you clone a github
template you go and fill in the bits and
you're in in your of that you need to
know and then you're done so it's it's
just enough javascript that i go oh look
javascript i'm writing javascript look
at me um uh but i don't have to be a
real expert i i know nothing about
javascript all right
anyone else
cool
uh but open telemetry um uh it's got
good.net support for example
um
cloudvent doesn't need any support for
our language um but acn kpo has
documented developers in the community
so it's not like we're left out in the
cold right some places
all right
cool
thanks very much
remember you want to put the green
ticket in the box outside
i got another talk tomorrow by the way
hustle and flow and that's about how you
model event-driven architectures how you
figure out how to use events between
systems
so please come to that if you're
interested in events
you